[Music]
in sue crazy news oh it's either China
or the US you guys know if you put paper
like this wrap it up you could punch
better really I was about to do that
just feels like [ __ ] brass knuckles a
judge tells a woman who has sued too
many people that she is no longer
welcome in court oh yes so anymore
what if you always win them where's this
from what are [ __ ] sue an ass [ __ ]
is just one judge that's like don't come
to me anymore
or is it just a whole court there was
someone in Sacramento I believe that was
in a wheelchair and would go around
looking for places that didn't fit code
like oh I mean that's the a da though
they do that all day all day did I think
they just have a wheelchair one person
though it was like the same person they
shut down they shut down like everyone's
like favorite burger joint that sucks
people yes good easy or she's [ __ ]
miserable so the sixth place in Ontario
Canada wrong woman
Canadian supposed to be nice I didn't
know they sued well this woman does
she's probably American or moved up
there Chinese American Canadian you
can't be chasing American Chinese making
it cool cuz you're married no it's just
cuz experienced Chinese Americans don't
sue they just ask you for cash right
then and there or they write a [ __ ]
angry Facebook post
yo Pat hahaha on yup they leave a bad
review on your business so this woman
her name is Theo Reyes she's 50 years
old this is what she looks like I'm just
gonna let that be I just have a Victoria
Secret shopping bag of [ __ ] of course
yes shopping bags what that of she's
like I'm gonna head up the mall and go
to the court yeah yeah she looks like
she that's her job is to sue that
professional Stuart so this woman can't
wait to sue she does have
a law degree but she isn't licensed to
practice law because she's a loser I
don't know why exactly
I think she's a [ __ ] loser cuz she's
leeching off people and she's making a
profession off of stealing pretty much
because she is like so crazy in the past
five years she's already sued thirty
people or companies or organizations
will stop math I [ __ ] hate this lady
yeah and so she has now been deemed Vic
fascias litigants what that means is
that she is just pursuing legal action
just to harass or some do people so
that's Karma's gonna be a [ __ ]
something real is gonna happen and she
can't sue she's been that cattle Talon
ass [ __ ] since she was a kid maybe I
would have had hated it be in her class
I hate her already I don't even or I'm
sure she's a nice lady
just a couple flaws you're judging
what's your last name she looks like
that [ __ ] little kid oh that's [ __ ]
her with a [ __ ] backstraight throwing
the ball up at the face Joe is picking
his boogers at putting it under the
table
[ __ ] [ __ ] I remember you I'm Terry
US Attorney General has even stated that
she has been abusing the courts process
and it's been a huge waste of judicial
and public research mmm throw her ass in
jail
yeah what No so now that she's no longer
welcome in court so she can't start any
more cases but she can defend herself if
someone Sue's her
oh I'll be tied if people start [ __ ]
her over he should all just sue her yeah
just start throwing [ __ ] down yeah cuz
all these times that she's been suing
people she's been representing herself
she's wasted about five minutes of my
life so I'll sue her she's the kind of
girl that would like go on a date and
then if the guy's dick is small she'll
sue him so she wasn't up to par with the
service I expected
[ __ ] how many times has she won that's
a good question I don't know how many
times but I do know that she's won that
feel a few 34:30
then you shouldn't then she is
unfortunate luck right or what there are
what if she yeah you know legitimate
yeah or even semi-legitimate yeah so
she's sued successful men that she's had
relationships with they all have small
dicks yeah she also sued a pawn shop big
dry-cleaning business lawyers who have
opposed her in the day in the courtroom
okay
and a complete stranger and also bank
employees so she just has a long history
of hurt defending yourself in I just
hope she gets ran over by a school bus
what'd she do for a living you said she
has a law degree but she's not a lawyer
yeah I don't really she does this
professional maybe smaller in these
cases yeah they're all small claims yeah
yeah and then like she's going after
like her rich ex-boyfriends - she looked
hot that's probably why I trap everybody
yeah uh she's sucking that old dick back
in the 90s she was she won the title of
Miss Black Ontario in 1989 she's black
and there's a Miss black interior
competition she's black okay show it to
you again in the night mimic let me get
my bifocals on for you journey to get
glasses through oh she has a black lady
she looked like Hispanic or something
come over here like I don't know there
are B it's also raised right bar neck
goes black after tone or she could be
domenica belly belly second what else is
there when she won st. mark bean
Jamaican you're going
beyond Caribbeans not a place of country
it's the whole hey hey hey Chacon what's
that one country in South America
that's life black people but it's like
on the north side Brasilia come in
between the little countries next to
button Isabella and another one I know
it's Peru the colonies like at the tip
of my tongue but we're not talking about
South America so don't count let's keep
going yeah so when she won the title
back then of the hooker award black
Ontario so she ended up suing the
organization because she was why didn't
we see that cuz yeah is this when it
started is this like the start of this
street she's like this feels good was
your origin story she's like a [ __ ]
superhero yeah I like it the [ __ ]
Marvel sewer it's so good what's wrong
with like pipes and [ __ ] black so she
sued the organization because they took
the tiara away from her because of the
fact that she failed to attend many
functions so they took the tear away she
ended up suing them what the serious is
black on Miss black Ontario well for the
prizes that she was owed which included
four hundred thousand dollars and a car
so she [ __ ] up
she's wait that's a big-ass prize half a
million dollars to be Miss black Ontario
that's worth a [ __ ] so why the [ __ ]
didn't you just go to the [ __ ]
adventure every black goes about the
rund Ontario starts to compete in this
thing he's too busy stealing people she
could have been to the events that's she
felt like mr. white just kidding films
there white mr. yellow mr. white
black mr. brown yes socio stripped over
title then and then she ended up
dropping that lawsuit and she blamed it
on a misunderstanding it's not like the
loss or any of that do you think so this
is like a superhero story so she's like
sad she lost her $400,000 and now she's
gonna go give it to the man and sue them
all back look I'm gonna get four hundred
thousand dollars worth of suing well I'm
not gonna what if the rich guys just
like [ __ ] use their for [ __ ] and
she's like oh yeah you want to do that
then I'm gonna use you for your money
yeah sounds pretty accurate yeah sounds
like la so it's like it's all revenge
but what sucks is at the beginning of
this movie
usually the superhero has their powers
at the beginning of this movie her
powers taken away
he's no longer allowed to sue so what
happens when you start the movie with
Batman and now I can't fly or see [ __ ]
or have x-ray vision that was like
Batman Tory wasn't it really I think so
was a bad movie he had a bright I had a
broken back he started with a broken
back did him uh uh one of them he was
like old God yeah he's like rehabbing
yeah the newest one he's old yeah and
then he had to go do push-ups and then
turn into Rocky Batman dance it's the
montage
[Laughter]
yeah but she even had one of her rich ex
boyfriends pay for schooling school fees
for one of her kids it was about
extractions to get a job two kids one of
them is the University she has a younger
daughter how old is she fifty
she's so accomplished she's probably
training them in her ways to you felt
like little proto geez yeah I think
there are a lot of people that find like
loopholes and laws and loopholes in this
and they didn't try to get like burn up
the system feels like can you imagine
aspiring to be like someone who leeches
off the success of others and being okay
with that like a lot of people do that
with the house of Canadians you guys are
always apologizing but in this case
she's are never apologizing and just
suing I hope you guys enjoy this video
for more please subscribe to our Channel
and you can check out the last video
right here
[Music]